I was on the set of the new installment
in the blockbuster transformers
franchise they're taking us back to the
beginning when bumblebee was just a
plain old beat-up you got people out
there who need you
what's happening here tonight tonight
explosion 21 year old Hailee Steinfeld's
making history is the first type of
female lead in just 4.3 billion dollar
franchise that also stars newcomer
George led the board Junior my character
Charlie will is a total badass she is a
mechanic now this takes place in the 80s
you guys weren't even born that's like
the present Noby music can help you say
what you're feeling try this
[Music]
bumblebees origin story takes place 20
years before the events of the first
Transformers film also making an
appearance John Cena
tell me a little bit about who you play
how you fit into this story I am a very
authoritative figure in Sector 7 and the
Tru transformers freaks will know what
I'm talking about now even though this
movie takes place in the 80s bumblebee
takes the form of this awesome 1967 VW
Bug now hundreds of man-hours thousands
of dollars went into building eight of
these babies from the ground up how
would you classify yourself as a driver
I'm for you shotgun oh yeah your job is
good now just to be clear I made that
set visit before John and Nikki called
off their engagement but it's very nice
to see that they're working on the
relationship and hope it works out of
course
[Music]